I just want everyone to know that I'm
telling the truth
Jordan woods going the distance to
defend herself that's the most important
part of the story to me is the truth the
22 year old took a lie detector test on
Jada Pinkett Smith's read table talk
after the Tristan Thompson cheating
scandal giving fans a closer look at her
interview at the table back in March
where she broke her silence in the rumor
shipped up with Tristan while he was
still dating her best friend Kylie
Jenner sister Khloe Kardashian I'm just
asked you straight up okay
did you sleep with Tristan never God
never thought another consideration
never happened I never will I and that's
why I'm willing to be put up to the test
attached me to a lie-detector whatever
it is I need people to know the truth
and more importantly I need the people
involved to know the truth
Jada says they hired a forensic
polygraphist with more than 25 years of
experience to administer the test and in
the never-before-seen clip Jordan admits
to kissing Tristan at a party when asked
whether things went further Jordan made
her stance no did you have sexual
intercourse with Tristan Thompson no you
definitely passed and I believe you're
being truthful on the test
Jada's mother and co-host Adrian
Banfield Jones also revealed that
despite reports Jordan did in fact
apologize for her role in the scandal
and that she saw the text messages there
were a lot of untruths that were put out
there and when I was about the fact that
there wasn't an apology from Jordan
right right right right right from the
text messages that I saw that that is
not necessarily the case got it right so
don't be ednan this out of the show no
word on where Jordans relationship with
the family stands today
but when et spoke with Jordan in June
she wanted to move on money doesn't stop
world doesn't stop and hopefully
everyone is just
you know going forward and Chloe feels
the same I don't think there needs to be
negativity on anywhere I think it's just
a story that's being told but anybody
picking aside or you know condemning any
human I think this is a part of life I'm
not saying it wasn't working it yeah
Chloe even took to Instagram earlier
this month writing quote I have moved on
found forgiveness and wish you only
happiness and joy
[Music]